hello everyone and do not be afraid I
will continue my towel versus bought
tunic series but as a lot of you have
requested it and it seems like the
reasonable thing to do I decided to
throw this one in like I mentioned in my
yesterday's video on March 8 1942 the
world was one of its greatest chess
players ever of course I'm talking about
Jose roll kappa blanka but one year and
one day after that another player was
born young Bobby here and some 30 years
later he will become the world chess
champion so it's his birthday I thought
it would be a nice gesture to show a
nice game by him for those of you who
maybe read or have a copy of my 60
memorable games by Bobby Fischer this is
the first game from that book we have
Robert James Fisher with the white
pieces against James T Sherwin and I
haven't found the information about how
strong Sherman was at the time this game
was played but his highest you will ever
achieved was over 2400 so I imagine it
was a very strong player as Bobby
Fischer was only 14 years old here it
was played in 1957 it's the new jersey
open and this game was played in the
last round of this tournament a couple
of months before this tournament but we
won the Junior Chess Championship and he
won an incredible prize of a hundred and
twenty-five dollars so that's a lot of
money for a young boy in in those days
but let's see this game and as Fischer
says in his book Sherman didn't really
make any mistakes in this game but he
failed to make some very moves to
equalize with black but we'll see how
Fischer deals with that
so Fischer opens with E 4 and we have c5
the Sicilian Knight to f3 East 6 and
here Fischer goes for d3 in his younger
days this was his favorite move as it
kind of reminded it's kind of like the
King's Indian but only reversed so nice
to see 6 we have g3 Knight to f6 and now
Bishop to g2 Bishop to e7 Fischer
castles and here Sherman also castles
another idea is d5 but Sherman has
another idea
curving castles Knight B to d2 and now
rook to b8 and this rook to b8
Fisher says that Sherman pleaded with
his little pinky as Canada the mystery
to the move but Fisher wasn't very
impressed by it official continued rook
to e1 d6 mouse e3 and here b6 and Fisher
consider this position to be relatively
good for black although he thought that
pawn to b5 was even better
so d4 by Fisher Queen to c7 and now II
five and this Queen to c7 move it's it's
the reason Fischer manages to pull off
'if I've better than Queen to c7 Fischer
suggests that seek a person before
opening up the C file for the Queen and
only then play in Queen c7 but okay
Queen c7 and now II five and here
Knight to d5 is played which causes
black a lot of problems but the 9th to
d7 is no better if Knight to d7 then e
captor son d6 Bishop characters and
Mountain Knight to e4 pawn captures
night captor son d6 Queen captures on d6
and now Bishop to f4 and this of course
attacks the Queen the Queen has to move
and then black loses the rook so if you
wanna stop this you have to push a 5 but
that's no better simply Knight captures
Knight captures and now pawn captures
and white gets his piece back and he
will be up upon so after this if I've
move Knight to d7 only only brings
problems for black so servant rise
Knight to d5 and here we had you capture
some d6 Bishop captures and now again
Knight to e4 and here black has a lot of
problems both night and Bishop are
occupying the defiled the queen is ready
to attack those pieces c4 is coming so
black has to make a very unpleasant
choice of pushing see for himself so he
does that
but now White has a very solid Center
and now Fischer can concentrate on
attacking the Kings side Knight captures
on d6 Queen captures and mount Knight to
g5 so what do you do here this was
actually the last good moment in the
game for sure when to play h6
but he decided he doesn't want to go for
that he played Knight c3 7 he didn't
wanna spoil the Kings position with the
idea that after
attacks h7 that he will block with
Knight to g6 but this doesn't really
work as well seeing the game first plays
Knight to see - he threatened Queen to
c2 he threatens checkmate on h7 so nice
to g6 this was Sherman's idea when he
played Knight d7 now comes h4 and now
serving blocks h5 would Knight to f6
and now it seems that Sherman is
defending everything the pawn can't be
pushed to h v h7 is very well protected
both Knights are covering the King so
what can you do here well there is this
idea of Bishop to f4 so if the night
wasn't guarding at 4
you could play Bishop to f4 and win the
rook and this is exactly what Fisher
does here in this position Fischer
played Knight captures on h7 and now
black has a lot of problems of course if
you capture with the King then Bishop to
f4 is coming and white wins the rook
because the night and g6 is now pinned
so after Knight captures on h7 black had
to respond with Knight captures on h7
but this is no better now Fischer simply
continues with h5 removing the defender
of DF for square and here Knight to e7
simply runs into Bishop to f4 and black
has no control plays game over so
Sherman tried a very interesting idea
here he tried night to h4 and you'll see
why this and the idea is interesting
Fischer played Bishop to f4 Queen to d8
and you can see that Sherman is a very
strong and resourceful player
now if Fischer would simply continue by
grabbing the rook if Bishop captures
then Sherman has Knight captures and g2
King captures and Bishop the b7 check
you have to block this and now Queen
captures Bishop and black would have a
lot better position here with two pieces
for the rook but Fischer of course isn't
gonna fall for this after Queen to d8
the Fischer simply plays G characters on
h4 and the rook NBA is still attacked
and here you don't really have a good
move with the rook as both bishops are
slicing all the way there
so this this rook is doomed but again
Sherman tries a trick against Bobby he
plays rook to b7 and here again he's
hoping for Bishop captures rook
if Bishop characters Reuben and Bishop
captures Bishop and then with the weak
King position and this very strong light
square bishop Sherman would definitely
have compensation for the exchange
but Fisher isn't interested in the rook
Fisher pushes h6 he continues attacking
the Kings side Queen captures on h4 we
have H capture sin g7 and now can
capture sin g7 and this is now the move
that Fisher describes as suicidal blacks
last hope will be something to maybe
play rook to d8 rook to d5 and maybe
transfer the rope to h5 but that's a lot
of moves and what white would also have
a say in this
but Shirin played King after sin g7 and
now comes Fischer's onslaught rook to e4
now Fischer is threatening Bishop to e5
Czech winning the Queen as a discovery
from the rook will open up so Queen to
h5 and now rook to e3 again with a
terrible threat of rock to h3 attacking
the Queen and when the Queen moves the
h7 night if the Queen blocks then Bishop
to e4 is coming so Sherman locks this
down would f5 and now nevertheless rook
to h3 Queen goes back to e8 and now
Fischer can win a lot of material here
he can grab the rock on b7 he can play
rook Bishop h6 check winning the rock on
f8 so he can win a lot of material here
but he feels there is something more in
the position he plays at Bishop to e5
check Knight to f6 blocking and now
Queen to d2 with the idea of coming to G
if I would check and picking up the
knight on f6 so King to have seven and
now Queen to g5 nevertheless and you
have to defend the night Queen to e7
if you try to defend the night with King
to e7
now the rook and King defending the
knight you're simply getting checkmated
rook to h7 check as the knight on f6 is
pinned rogue blocks simply Queen
captures now the rook is pinned King
moves rook captures you have to capture
Queen captures and after King moves
Bishop to f6 check roblox Queen captures
e7 this is checkmate
so after Queen to g5 threatening the
capture
Queen to e7 was played but now simply
better captures Queen captures and work
to h7 check now with this check the
bishop and rook are I in that rook on b7
so King has the move and now the very
elegant Queen captures on f6 and here if
if black captures the Queen white simply
captures the rook on b7 and the white
will be up to much material a bishop and
the rook against the rook so Sherman
could have very well resigned here but
he decided to play on
he played rook captures on h7 and now
Fischer simply played Bishop to c6 check
and it was in this position that James D
Sherman resigned the game black really
doesn't have anything to do here the
King can't move if you walk with the
rook you lose the rook if you walk with
the bishop then Queen captures on e6
with the check King has to move then you
can simply bring the rock into the game
or what or pin the bishop first then
bring the rook into the game and it's
all over
so yeah after Bishop to c6 check he
resigned the game and a wonderful
victory for young 14 year-old Bobby
Fischer in the New Jersey open in 1957
so does the game I do hope you enjoyed
this little brilliancy by 14 year old
Bobby Fischer on his birthday March 9th
I would like to thank middle Muhammad
and dammit Latour it's a foreign to my
channel think a lot to really appreciate
it and I'm very glad you're still
enjoying my content as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
with another video from the Talbot annex
series thank you and I'll see you soon